Así es vaya sorpresa
hasta hoy
y el momento de este viernes en que se
conoció este anuncio los candidatos que
iban a competir dentro de Unión por la
patria que es la coalición oficialista
eran Eduardo guado de Pedro
ministro del interior y
Daniel y el embajador en Brasil y no
ellos eran las personas que iban a
disputar la posibilidad de competir por
la presidencia en las primarias de
agosto de este año sin embargo apareció
esta noticia hace muy pocas horas y
cuando se acerca el cierre de la
inscripción de los candidatos que será
este sábado a medianoche y esto cambia
el escenario seguramente también llovió
a estos dos precandidatos que estaban
avanzando con su precandidatura de forma
muy fuerte de hecho Eduardo de Pedro
había sacado un video en el que se
presentaba como candidato a la
presidencia Daniel que no se iba a bajar
de su precandidatura pero nos
encontramos con este anuncio de unidad y
había cierta sospecha de que algo no
estaba del todo cerrado por un lado en
el hecho de que no había salido ningún
anuncio oficial de Unión por la patria y
porque no había habido ningún ninguna
alocución ni ninguna observación
invención por parte de Cristina
Fernández de kirchner que es la
principal miembro de esta coalición de
la unión por la patria pero hoy salió el
anuncio oficial diciendo que será Sergio
mansa el precandidato presidencial del
oficialismo